voici dany boon
dany boon mesdames messieurs comment ça
va mieux a alors vous savez que votre
passage dans cette émission a changé ma
vie mais je suis ça j'étais pas peu fier
la magnétosphère oui et là vous faites
un truc que j'ai parlé avec votre
coiffeur l'arrêt pour vous faites une ré
comme ça je sais pas quoi je voulais
chose d'autre mais je sais pas il m'a
dit oui bindis au millimètre bien sûr je
veux une autre idem avec judith quand on
vous regardera talent et pas ici mais ça
c'est pas souvent c'est que dévoile avec
vous aussi vous regardons 17 pourquoi
vous ne tentez pas une autre notre coupe
de cheveux hpc si je faisais la rive
l'autre côté ça ailleurs
merci les enfants
ah oui ça me va très bien
vraiment je ne me souvenais plus à quel
point vous avez cette coupe de cheveux
de ringard l'époque ces prélèvements
quand ces déviances et les images noir
et blanc meilleure couleur non c'est en
tous les cas merci donc à surgy votre
vie tous complets toutes les femmes et
tous les hommes aussi
alors l'olympia et non du réchauffé le
vrai m c'est au gaz en parfait état dans
le ganil boon du 12 février jusqu'au 2
mars spectacle également disponible en
cassette vidéo vous savez comment on
fait attention
franck